- [Alexandra] When markets get choppy,
investors can pull out
to save their money, or
they can cast their lines
for discounted stock, aiming
for a bigger profit later on.
This second option is
called buying the dip
and it's been a popular
strategy in the markets
for years now.
It was even touted
during the crash of 2008.
- This is not a time to
be selling your stocks.
It's times like these, where
people really make money
because stocks become a better value.
- [Alexandra] But so far
in 2022, buying the dip
hasn't paid off as well as in the past.
Markets are volatile
and in this environment,
buying the dip can be risky.
- What we're seeing is
that after people step in
to buy the stock market dip,
the S&P500 has kept falling the day after.
So that means that you're
sitting on a loss pretty quickly.
- [Alexandra] But even these circumstances
haven't stopped investors who
want to bring in a big catch.
Here's why it's such
an attractive strategy
but nearly impossible to time.
Let's zoom out, buying
the dip is when investors
purchase assets after they
have dropped in price,
on the assumption that their
value will bounce back.
- What we've seen over
the past few decades
is that sharp downturns
in the stock market
have often been followed
by these huge rebounds.
So people that have sat on the sidelines
during say the financial crisis
or the March 2020 COVID
crash, have watched stocks
kind of go up after those instances.
- [Alexandra] Investors willing
to dive in, tend to have
one of three main motivations.
First, some investors want to
buy into growing companies.
They care less about the price
of the stock and more about
the opportunity to reel in a company
they think will experience
significant growth in the future.
Other investors look for
stocks with upward momentum,
meaning rising prices.
They're most interested in
timing the bottom of the dip
so they can maximize profits
and then there's investors
who want cheap stocks.
They don't care as much
about how fast and how far
their stocks will grow,
but they're excited
that stocks that were previously expensive
are now cheap enough for them to grab.
Mainly they think the
stocks they're buying
will keep going up.
Whatever their motivation,
if a lot of investors
attempt this strategy
the result can have another effect,
one that has played out
in the past few years
as more individual investors
have entered the market.
- Individual investors have
become such a prominent force
in markets in recent years.
They've stampeded into the markets,
they've bought a record amount of stocks.
So some analysts and strategists do say
that they can kind of provide a backstop
to the market and help support
the market during volatility.
- [Alexandra] Sometimes
when enough investors
try to catch cheap stocks,
they can actually reverse
the downward trajectory.
Take for example, the 2008 crash,
after the housing bubble burst.
It sent markets into a
tailspin, but by 2009,
many investors began
reentering the market,
pushing up the prices of cheap stocks.
- [Alexandra] Investors halted
a three day losing streak,
sending stocks broadly
higher on a weaker dollar
and better than expected
home sales numbers.
- [Alexandra] It was known
as the 2009 Dash for Trash.
- We saw that that prolonged
downturn and that steep selloff
was followed by an incredible recovery.
An 11 year bull market for stocks.
- [Alexandra] the MSCI
All Country World Index
ended up returning its
best annual performance
on record in 2009,
just after its worst performance in 2008.
- People who said the
stock market is too scary
for me right now,
they missed out on those
mammoth, mammoth gains
and may have regretted it.
- [Alexandra] Strategists
say that since then,
investors have been
conditioned to buy the dip
and it's made individual investors money,
at least until 2022.
Since the Federal Reserve has made
the biggest interest
rate increase since 2000,
some think a recession is ahead.
- This is a huge shift
for financial markets
and that's one of the key reasons
we've seen this volatility.
- [Alexandra] It's an example
of why it can be so hard
for investors to time the dip,
because stocks can keep on falling.
Vanda research estimates the average
individual investor portfolio
peaked late in 2021,
and then tumbled, losing an
average of about 28% by May 9th.
With all the dangers
associated with buying the dip,
it's no wonder that
analysts consider it risky.
- If you choose to buy the dip,
you can't expect, you know,
the market to bounce immediately.
It could take days, weeks,
months, or even years
for it to rebound
and for you to pocket
a profit on that trade.